hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and i am back with
another software video this one a
tutorial about how to download the
latest version of skype 4.1 beta
now you may or may not know um that i do
have a skype id and i do often take
calls and most of the time chats from my
subscribers who have you know quick
little brief questions to ask and uh
this is actually a new idea because i
was considering going uh going live over
the summer doing a few you streams or
blog tvs depending on
who uh tells me what to do more on
twitter
but i was considering doing a few blog
tvs taking live skype calls really
getting uh getting my name out there
onto youtube onto twitter etc uh so i'm
gonna show you guys everyone who's
watching us now how to watch or how to
download the latest version of skype 4.1
beta for windows and basically all
you're going to have to do is visit this
link up here skype.com and all this this
will be in the description
you can just control click it and open
in a new tab and it says you can
you can test drive the latest version
for windows and i will go ahead and hit
that download now button and we'll go
through the installation process quickly
first of all this will work whether or
not you are already running a version of
skype or you don't have it yet so go
ahead and hit the run button
if you're using firefox hit the open
button
and we're going to hit the run button
again because we do trust uh
this trust this retailer so now we're
going to exit out of our web browser
because we really don't need it anymore
we're actually going to go through the
installation process right here
hit the i agree install button and
basically i'm just going to tell you a
little bit about skype if you don't
already know it's a free pc to pc uh
calling client if you will
if you download it you can obviously if
you have a webcam and a microphone you
can uh basically do face-to-face chats
you can do calling if you actually uh
pay for a skype plan you can call
landlines and cell phones as well and uh
it's it's fairly good rates you pretty
much get to call anywhere you want in
the world and it's pretty cool
so i'm gonna
wait for the skype 4.1 beta to install
now right now i'm currently running
skype 4.0 beta so
this is simply updating my version of
skype you'll keep all your contacts and
all that kind of stuff etc so i'm going
to pause this video and come back um
once skype is done installing be right
back
all right guys this is what it looks
like when you finish installing the
latest version of skype it'll actually
open up the skype welcome screen and
sign you in if you're already there uh
so obviously i haven't signed in a
little bit so there's people trying to
contact me but basically it says welcome
to skype get a minute take a minute to
set up your microphone uh add your
contacts and all that but i actually
still i can exit out of this because i
have all my contacts um and they're all
in skype now i don't actually need to
show you guys their names but that
that's how you do it you have the latest
version of skype already downloaded and
installed no need to um
no need to do any further steps you can
now go on and use it use the new
features i heard there's some new screen
sharing uh features involved i will
definitely do a full overview video if
you guys like of the newest version of
skype but overall that is it and thanks
for watching this video and i hope you
enjoyed the tutorial uh so thanks for
watching guys peace